with colombia my friend simone went in
heavy but mexico is a real mess let's
start with the basics mexico officially
the united mexican states is the 14th
largest country in the world and the
11th most populated with its 126 million
inhabitants politically it's a federal
republic composed of 31 states plus the
capital district mexico city located in
north america the country's border to
the north by the united states to the
south by belize and guatemala to the
east by the gulf of mexico and the
caribbean sea and to the west by the
pacific ocean from an economic point of
view looking at the national gdp we
could consider mexico the 16th largest
economy in the world but if we dig
deeper we find several negative
socioeconomic indicators such as high
rates of poverty and inequality that
have increased during the pandemic and
indeed there are quite a few mexicans
who claim that the country's main
problem is not drugs but that this is
just a consequence of another
omnipresent factor poverty according to
studies conducted in 2020 by carnival 44
of the population or over 55 million
people lived in poverty despite the
serious lack of civil and human rights
including one of the highest homicide
rates in the world mexico's political
system strange as it may seem is that of
a representative democracy and it's
maybe thanks to the process of
liberalization that the country
experienced between the 1970s and the
new century that criminal groups have
found fertile ground for their illicit
operations among them stand out the
cartels that as the name suggests are
criminal associations with the aim of
promoting and controlling the activities
of drug trafficking but also weapons
migrants and organs thanks to the
expansion of these groups the weight of
mexico in the criminal world has
increased a lot originally the
institutional revolutionary party which
ruled for 71 years held the political
monopoly in an authoritarian system
shaping over time what's known as the
perfect dictatorship the executive power
was predominant over the legislative and
judicial so a fake democratic system
developed based on non-competitive
elections in which the state greatly
reduced civil liberties in doing so the
party controlled most of the economic
and social sectors of the country
denying the possibility of emergence of
social movements ending up dictating the
discipline of illegal activities such as
drug trafficking over the years social
phenomena such as urbanization student
and workers movements internal migration
industrialization and increased levels
of education however have opened the
bridge in the mexican central power
inaugurating in the second half of the
20th century a difficult process of
expansion of political space in addition
a series of reforms of the electoral
system allowed other political forces
such as the conservative right the
national action party and the party of
the democratic revolution full
competition in the municipal state and
national spheres this democratic
transition reached its peak in 2000 with
the presidential victory of vicente fox
quesada at the same time the power
structure changed with a clearer
separation of state powers and greater
decentralization in favor of local and
municipal governments however this
drastic change has created new
opportunities for profit and investment
for narcos access to the free market and
the elimination of fair barriers
especially after the entry into force of
the north american free trade agreement
in 1994 tripled the level of trade with
the united states and opened new ways
for trading illegal goods in addition
the policies that followed eroded the
mexican social fabric greatly reducing
the income of about 50 percent of the
mexican population which fell below the
poverty level pushing millions of people
especially young people to enter the
illegal economy another deep-rooted
problem is the weakness if not in
existence of the state in the internal
areas of the country where successive
governments have always been unable to
deal with the threat of criminal
organizations preferring instead to join
them with a consequence that the most
fragile social categories such as women
children indigenous peoples and migrants
pay the price the increase in the number
of cases of enforced disappearances in
which the state authorities are often
involved contributes to a climate of
total mistrust of the police and justice
agencies which appear unable to provide
definitive answers among the most easily
corruptible subjects are the municipal
authorities who often underpaid by the
federal government are at the mercy of
the criminal power of cartels and
organized gangs for years the country
has been defined with the term narco
state or narco-democracy and this comes
from the combination of narcos political
power and law enforcement a dangerous
link that results in silence impunity
and connivance of those who should
protect mexicans in front of evidence
facts think that in the global ranking
of impunity 2020 mexico occupies the
60th place out of 69 countries analyzed
with the rate of impunity 10 times
higher than the global average let's
take a look at some recent cases in 2018
in acapulco all members of the local
police department were arrested for
suspected ties to organized crime and in
2019 genaro garcia luna federal police
chief and then minister of public
security ended up in jail motivation
turning a blind eye to the movement of
drug shipments in the territory in the
rare cases when investigations are
opened they always go slowly and end up
shedding light in the wrong places but
to understand why drug trafficking finds
such fertile ground in mexico we can
look at a geographical map the country
is strategically located representing an
international hub for illegal substances
natural resources weapons and people
many of them from the south american
continent moreover the particular
confirmation of the territory with
mangroves huge deserts in the north
tropical forests and large mountain
ranges including the eastern and western
sierra madre allows criminal groups to
hide from the government army and
establish areas where they can freely
cultivate marijuana and opium poppy from
which let's remember heroin is processed
otherwise labs are set up for the
production of synthetic drugs such as
fentanyl or methamphetamine both of
which are in great demand in the united
states a country that for years has been
immersed in an epidemic of opium
overdoses but mexico's long coastline
also facilitates under the table
operations and port cities such as
veracruz lazaro cardenas or manzanillo
have become central bastions for many
groups facilitating the entry of drugs
weapons and drug processing chemicals
into their ports it's likely that on
many of the containers that arrive there
is a dragon printed certainly not in
plain sight but with an undeniable
origin yes because businessmen and
traders affiliated to the chinese triads
that send the materials destined to be
transformed into synthetic drugs such as
hefedrine in order to evade controls in
the country of origin have for some time
moved their labs to india and from there
send the products by ship to mexico
where they are skillfully synthesized ok
but how does the united states influence
the mexican criminal situation we have a
fork in the road the first road is the
one of the flourishing u.s market and
its endless demand for narcotics the
second is the one of the prohibitionist
policy that the various us governments
have tried for at least a century to
instill in the leaders of mexico city
over time the so-called war on drugs and
washington's interference in mexican
affairs has shown itself through
unilateral actions of border
interdiction such as operation intercept
of 1969 and in the financing of aerial
fumigation campaigns of opium and
marijuana crops sea operation condor of
1975. the attention of the white house
towards mexico was also expressed by
planning undercover operations of u.s
federal agents in particular the dea
since the 90s however security
cooperation has grown culminating in
2008 with the entry into force of the
initiative amerida the most serious
attempt to put on paper at a bilateral
level the fight against the drug cartels
however if we are talking about
trafficking we must mention another
scourge that of the illegal traffic of
migrants according to the most reliable
estimates every year at least the 2
million people including children
traveling alone in search of fortune
cross or try to cross the border into
the united states that's why as the los
angeles times reports nearly 25 percent
of the 45 million immigrants in north
america are of mexican origin also in
this case the activity is under the
control of criminal organizations in
complicity with mexican law enforcement
agencies over the years there have been
cases where migrants were arrested by
police officers and then sold to various
criminal groups with the goal of
obtaining ransoms from their families
and i leave you to imagine the end of
those who couldn't afford such sums the
numbers speak of 84 000 desapresidos two
years ago some of whom disappeared in
acid with all this data it won't sound
strange to you to hear that mexico is
one of the most violent countries in the
world according to mexico's national
institute of statistics and geography as
of 2018 the country has maintained a
rate of 29 murders per 100 000
inhabitants a rate higher even than
countries that have historically had a
higher rate such as el salvador with its
20 homicides per 100 000 inhabitants in
2020 or colombia with a rate of less
than 24 to give you just an idea of the
magnitude even though one shouldn't
compare countries with such distant and
different geographical contexts in italy
in 2019 the homicide rate was 0.53 100
000 inhabitants however among the most
affected areas are the states of
michoacan tamaulipas and zacatecas where
clashes between gangs are almost the
order of the day often these clashes
also end up involving civilians as
happened during the massacre of
ayotsinapa with the disappearance of a
bus carrying 43 students to the city of
iguala the boys were stopped by the
police arrested on charges of wanting to
join a protest and finally handed over
to the guerrero sunidos clan who killed
them and made the bodies disappear their
murder can be explained if we consider
that the students of escuela normale
rural are people of humble origins and
actively interested in the
socio-political problems that afflict
their land to the point that in recent
years hundreds of social fighters have
emerged from those classrooms a
criminalization unfortunately remained
unpunished due to the obstructionism of
many politicians local authorities and
journalists who spread false information
about the incident preventing the truth
from coming out or think of the massacre
of san fernando by the cartel de los
zetas in the summer of 2010 where 72 of
the 73 migrants bound for the united
states were kidnapped and brutally
killed the same fate then happened to
the judge in charge of the investigation
and you may ask has justice been done no
because it's worth repeating federal
institutions and drug traffickers go
hand in hand talking about violence in
mexico is also the same as talking about
gender violence the data at our disposal
speak for themselves according to a
government report in 2020 two-thirds of
mexican women aged 15 years and older
have experienced violence at least once
in their lives and also in the same year
feminiside has reached worrying heights
with a record of over 3 000 women killed
all this happens with almost complete
silence of the judicial authorities
evidence disappeared forensic analysis
that remain pending abandoned lines of
investigation make it seriously
difficult to fight the problem of
violence against women but now in order
to better understand this world
situation of chaos we should talk about
the real lords of the country the
drunkard tells even an uninformed person
knows that in the 90s the throne of the
king of cocaine was occupied by the
infamous pablo escobar who together with
the rival cartel of cali dominated the
international traffic of cocaine but in
the last two decades the supremacy of
mexican organizations in drug
trafficking has replaced the colombian
one becoming the main regional threat
and where do they practice their dirty
operations like smuggling tons of drugs
and thousands of illegal migrants of
course the us border and they do it
using extreme and unconditional violence
as an instrument of terror and control
of society however the border is not
accidental because the big cartels are
well aware that the dominance of this
area guarantees profits of millions of
dollars with which they constantly
self-finance their activities and how
were these realities born in 2006 in
mexico there were seven cartels
millennial sinaloa juarez tijuana the
golf cartel la familia michoacana and
the pacific cartel their birth was
facilitated by the proximity of the
united states the main global economy as
well as the largest consumer of drugs
simple supply and demand although the
production and consumption of substances
in mexico especially those derived from
the opium poppy and marijuana date back
to the end of the 19th century it was
after world war ii that things began to
take a warring turn in the 1960s drugs
such as those mentioned above began to
be produced in the states of sinaloa
durango chihuahua michoacan and guerrero
regions from which particularly sinaloa
it was easy to creep into the united
states one of the fundamental changes
then occurred in the 1980s when colombia
narcos shifted their coca roots from the
caribbean to mexico helping the
emergence of one of the first two major
organizations the guadalajara cardel led
by miguel gallardo nicknamed the
godfather the boss of bosses gallardo
was originally an agent of the mexican
federal judicial police el jefe quickly
became not only the first mexican to act
as a link with the colombian cartels in
their heyday but also the first to
become a point of reference for the
medellin cartel this link allowed him to
request a new form of payment if
gallardo was paid in cash for the
transport of cocaine from the mexican
border to the united states from a
certain moment onwards he began to
withhold 50 percent of the transported
product a fact that allowed the narcos
of the guadalajara cartel to transform
themselves from transporters into
distributors thereby greatly increasing
their profits although it was not the
only organization present this cartel
managed to gain a monopoly of the major
marijuana and opium producing areas as
well as the main access points to the us
border such as the states of baja
california and sonora and how could he
act undisturbed simple in addition to
his affiliates politicians and entire
police departments protected him
remember in 1985 gallardo's thugs
managed to kidnap and kill enrique
camarena a dea agent who was
investigating the organization's
trafficking the incident provoked the
more active involvement of the us agents
that ended with the arrest of the main
leaders of the cartel and the
fragmentation of the same with
guadalajara out of the way in the 1980s
three other large monopolistic groups
remained the tijuana juarez and sinaloa
cartels the competition between them
triggered the violence conflict from
which the latter emerged the winner
gaining control of the main routes
without forgetting its more
international dimension compared to its
competitors its overwhelming power
derived mainly from the cultivation of
the golden triangle between the states
of sinaloa durango and chihuahua and its
fiercest contrasts were with the rival
juarez cartel historically located in
the strategic border city of the same
name which experienced its period of
maximum splendor in the mid-1990s
despite its strong connections with
local clan groups the group ruled by
amado carrillo fuentes nicknamed the
lord of the skies due to the intensive
use of airplanes to bring drugs into the
u.s however seated ground to the sinaloa
cartel which managed to rest control of
the border city from him and confine him
to the state of chihuahua for a time
carrillo fuentes managed to create a
federation of alliances and
non-aggression facts to break off
hostilities between most of the rival
factions but at the time of his death in
july 1997 many of the former partners
became independent and came back to
fight for the spoils leading to the
dissolution of the already fragile
arrangement in 2004 what happens from
that time to the present day is another
story but for my sanity and yours as
well it's best that i end here if you
have followed me up to this point i
thank you for your attention and see you
in the next video ciao